[Musik]
in diesem video zeige ich euch meine top
fünf rezepte für die perfekte super bowl
party
ich werde jetzt schicken finger chicken
wings käse nachos verschiedene tipps und
super bowl sliders zu bereiten
jetzt startet mit dem ersten rezept für
die chicken wings verwende ich 200 gramm
sahne eine knoblauchzehe etwas salz und
pfeffer ein bisschen scharfe soße einen
rosmarin stengel 20 chicken wings und
100 gramm mehl die chicken wings werden
jetzt in eine marinade eingelegt und
zwar nehme ich dafür sahne
wir können doch botanisch verwenden dann
etwas salz und pfeffer den knoblauch
schreibe ich jetzt nicht sondern
schneidet ihnen einfach einmal durch so
kann das aroma abgeben und dann nämlich
die theater soße gibt ein bisschen was
dazu dann einen rosmarin stengel alles
gut verrühren und jetzt kommen hier die
hähnchenflügel mit rein
man könnte so ein mal durchhören
abdecken und dann einfach für mindestens
eine halbe stunde stehen lassen
jetzt gehts weiteren mitte in schicken
fingers für die chicken fingers verwende
ich 600 gramm hinten brust 100 gramm
mehl zweier etwas salz und pfeffer und
konflikt zum panieren jetzt braucht ihr
drei tiefe täler in den ersten teller
kommt das mehl in dem zweiten teil
kommen die eier salz und pfeffer
also einfach einen schuss warm hier
aufnehmen so ein löffelchen voll ganz
schön verrühren und hier kommen jetzt
konflikt ein
für die kur kam ohne nehme ich eine
reife avocados den saft einer halben
limette salz pfeffer und knoblauch und
olivenöl jetzt die avocado halbieren und
jetzt das avocado fleisch einfach mit
einem löffel raus kratzen und dann
ähnlich wieder mit einer gabel
zerdrücken oder mit einem mixer
zerkleinert da kommt jetzt der
limettensaft dazu die knoblauchzehe salz
und pfeffer und einfluss um ihnen für
die sorgt nämlich 200 gramm saure sahne
etwas limettensaft schnittlauch der
knoblauchzehe salz und pfeffer jetzt die
saure sahne dran
dafür gebe ich sie einfach in eine
rührschüssel da kommt etwas knoblauch
dazu dann etwas salz und pfeffer
schnittlauch und dann noch limettensaft
dazu für die tomaten zahlte wendig 250
gramm cocktail oder roman automaten eine
rote zwiebel 2 knoblauchzehen etwas
petersilie einen teelöffel honig den
saft von einer halben zitrone olivenöl 2
frühlingszwiebeln und wer möchte gibt
noch getrocknete oder frisches dazu ich
nehme jetzt einmal die tomaten und
schneidet sie in ganz feine würfel zeigt
ich noch die petersilie fein und
schneide die spiegel auch in feine
würfel
jetzt werde ich noch die fröhlichs
klebrigen die chilischote freien und den
knoblauch den rhein ich dazu jetzt noch
zitronensaft rhein ein bisschen honig
olivenöl salz umfasst jetzt einfach nur
noch alles schön berühren und dann
brauche ich nur noch ein päckchen
tortilla chips und 200 gramm käse am
stück jetzt habe ich alles vorbereitet
die chicken wings habe ich aus ihrem
sahne bad rausgeholt und einfach im meer
gebadet
jetzt habe ich ja auch schön paniert und
die liegt mir eigentlich nicht gebacken
werden sondern sie werden nur überbacken
da kommt jetzt ein bisschen was von der
salza drauf und jetzt den käse obendrauf
ich habe hier bereits frittierfett auf
170 grad erwärmt und jetzt kann ich
einfach nacheinander die schicken finger
und die chicken wings frittieren
[Musik]
ich hab bis jetzt in schälchen gegeben
jetzt kommt das ganze auf eine
holzplatte dann kommt da noch die
chicken fingers und die chicken wings
dazu dann kann man alles richtig schön
klicken
[Musik]
jetzt geht es weiter mit dem herzhaften
flyers
für den hefeteig nämlich einen würfel
hefe 200 gramm warmes wasser 30 gramm
zucker und 30 com zur verfügung
230 gramm g 4 2 eier ein kilo mehl vier
teelöffel salz und 160 gramm weiche
butter nehmen jetzt einfach zuerst das
wasser die hefe den zucker und dem
zuckerrübensirup und die zutaten kann
ich jetzt schon mal miteinander
vermischen einfach hier in der
rührschüssel unkompliziert das mehl noch
mit rein stadtarchiv wir dann gefeiert
dazu das salz und jetzt gar nicht erst
mal kneten
dann gebe ich jetzt noch nach und nach
das restliche mehl dazu und die weiche
butter den teig kann mich jetzt etwa
zehn minuten kneten lassen und dann
lasse ich ihnen jetzt hier für etwa eine
halbe stunde stunde aufgeben bei der
füllung könnt ihr entscheiden wie die
sliders schmecken sollen
ich verwende jetzt etwas fleisch dann
nämlich jetzt rindfleisch und macht das
hackfleisch auch selber
das heißt ich habe dann immer eine ganz
große menge die ich dann zubereitet und
ein teil von hackfleisch kann ich immer
gleich einfrieren und so spare ich mir
einfach ein bisschen arbeit
ich nehme jetzt direkt schon mal eine
panne denn ich kann jetzt auch noch die
zwiebel und knoblauchzehe durchlassen
so kommt auch noch fleisch aus nehme ich
hier noch die richtige menge an
hackfleisch raus geht jetzt alles in
eine pfanne und wettern die hackfleisch
mavs damit in zwiebel und knoblauchzehen
und dem olivenöl schön krümelig anbraten
für die sauce nehme ich da noch etwas
curry ketchup senf rote zwiebel
eingelegter rapelius conny chance und
etwas fetter käse so jetzt kann ich hier
die füllung fertig machen und zwar mit
salz und pfeffer würzen
jetzt kann ich die füllung einmal kurz
aufkochen lassen den herd ausmachen und
dann zur seite stellen und werde mich
dann erst mal wieder um die brötchen
kümmern denn wir müssen ja auch gefällt
werden und vor mich sehr richtig schön
zu einer sauberen kugel und werde aber
bevor ich sie hin die im mai vom rhein
lege dem iphone mit butter bestreichen
und dafür gebe ich einfach die butter
rein stellen das blech kurz auf dem herd
die im iphone mister induktions fähig
das heißt ich kann sie hier drauf
stellen auf kleine hitze und dann
schmilzt die butter und ich kann so
schön verstreichen jetzt hätte ich dich
hier direkt ins blech legen kann ich die
brötchen nach dem aufgehen noch mit
einem ei bestreichen
ganz vorsichtig mit sesam bestreuen und
dann schon direkt backen
ich habe sie direkt nach dem backen
bisher mit butter bestrichen und jetzt
lese ich sie hier am rand und kann
daraus stürzen erstmal zum aufschneiden
sehr schön und jetzt einmal halbieren
den boden habe ich jetzt hier schon
wieder rein gelegt da streichelt den
senf drauf dann kommt ihr ziel die
hackfleisch füllung drauf dann noch die
zwiebeln die gurken und die cala pi news
das habe ich jetzt alles von den
scheiben geschnitten dann noch etwas
schneller käse und ketchup darüber wenn
ihr möchtet
und dann können die brötchen schon
wieder in den backofen am besten kurz
vor verzehr damit sie dann wirklich
schön wahnsinn
der käse verläuft ein bisschen
[Musik]
ich wünsche euch viel spaß mit den
rezepten und viel spaß bei ihrer super
bowl party